so over the course of the last few days
a lot of you guys have been bombarding
me with the question of what's the
origin of Dormammu no I don't know if
it's because people are confusing me
with comic story and I'd love it's a
case or not but I figured why not like
why not run over the origin story of
Dormammu because this is like one of the
best-kept secrets in Marvel Comics like
unless you know where to look you're
never gonna find this origin story it's
actually insane it's not like you know
x-men origins worse literally just a
series of one shots that are origin
stories this is actually very well
hidden now having said that this story
is written by Roy Thomas and it comes
out of what's called the book of Ashanti
legends and lore of the Dark Dimension
and it literally just runs over the
which is the realm order Imam who hails
from now again because of the fact that
this focus is so much on the emphasis of
his origin story we're actually going to
have to add in a few tidbits of our own
because Roy Thomas really just assumes
that there are certain things that we
know of course with normal comics at the
time they didn't really publish things
based on the fact that everybody was
knew they would publish things with some
measure of an assumption that you
already knew things but because of the
fact that there are probably a lot of
people who are coming to my channel
based off the Doctor Strange film I'm
gonna provide you guys with the
information that's not really available
here in terms of background stuff so
initially we pick up with what is
inherently the Dark Dimension but at
this point in time the Dark Dimension is
not ruled by nor Mamun now when it comes
to alternate realities and this is
especially important when it comes to
Doctor Strange you have what's called
the multiverse it's literally just
multiple universes but not all universes
are even and this is the difference
between a dimension and a universe the
earth-616 continuity in Marvel Comics
the main model continuity that we have
right now with all-new all-different
model that is the Marvel Universe Asgard
is technically a universe the Dark
Dimension is technically a universe but
the reason why we call Asgard a
dimension and the reason why we call the
dark dimension a dimension is because
they're smaller than your regular
universe that's the huge difference here
it's really just size that makes the
difference between these two things now
admittedly people will use them
interchangeably although I don't know
anybody who refers to the realm of
Dormammu as the dark universe that is
usually called the dark dimension
I don't know anybody that refers to
Asgard as you know the Asgardian
universe that is call it the Asgardian
dimension but the fact remains here
that way you have things where they're
simply called dimensional locations
they're basically just universes except
they're smaller in size so instead of
having like countless you know galaxies
and so on and so forth you may have
something like the Dark Dimension where
there's just I'm sorry like as guard or
there's just like one territory and
that's it and as guard that's all there
is there's just as guard there's nothing
else there in the Dark Dimension you may
have like one planet and that's it
whereas in our universe and the Marvel
earth-616 universe you have galaxies and
you have planets and you have stars and
you have space dust and you have all
kinds of stuff out there so anyway
because this starts off with the dark
dimension we initially pick up with a
guy by the name of all not now all gnar
is currently the king of the dark
dimension he's literally the guy that's
ruling it the problem is that during
this era of the dark dimensions history
concepts like war concepts like conflict
those have basically gone away it's this
dark dimension has reached a higher
level of existence whereby they now
emphasize philosophy they now emphasize
science but it's much like Asgard in the
sense that magic has sort of intertwined
itself with science and so instead of
having a quart of scientist you have a
quart of scientist slash magicians or
wizards they basically take the two
concepts working hand in hand and then
achieve different forms of Technology
now what we also have is the realm of
the foul team now those of you guys who
have been around Marvel Comics for a
long time and know the super obscure
stuff you probably know about foul teams
so bear with me for a second because
there are a lot of people who don't like
we said there are all different kinds of
universes out there the foul team
dimension is quite literally a universe
made of energy or for the most part it's
made of energy but energy can be
transmuted and turned into other things
not only that these pallet in Ian's as
they're referred to are beings that are
basically born by magical energies there
is literally like the energies of the
universe just create life and so
somewhere along the line these beings
create life of their own the problem
here is that in this particular
situation one of the falt in Ian's name
Sena fur had given birth quote-unquote
to offspring in the form of Dormammu and
umar but instead of actually craving
mystical energies Dormammu
our craved matter now Roy Thomas is
being a little weird with words here
it's it's not as though Dormammu and
Umar crave like rocks and so on and so
forth but they recognize that their
ability to basically control these
mystical energies allow them to control
all forms of matter and so it's really
just a desire by them to explore the
full capabilities of their power the
issue with this is that the fountain
Ian's were nothing if not very dogmatic
in terms of how they view things which
is to say they were they view things to
the extreme
they said that we are mystical beings we
thrive on mystical energy we do not
delve in physical matter which is
tantamount to the equivalent of black
matter I guess a black magic within the
realm of the Falcons and so while centre
fir initially tried to curb this desire
of Dormammu and Umar for dark dark
matter ultimately it didn't work and in
response they quite literally turned
cinah fur into dark matter in response
the Falcons banished them to the dark
dimension now Roy Thomas doesn't
explicitly tell us in terms of you know
the story itself why the dark dimension
was chosen and in truth we don't really
need to worry about that I mean it's not
a major plot point so I guess it is kind
of a major plot point but the why is not
a major plot point because it's
basically him just saying this is just
where they ended up now it may very well
have been that the Falcon Ian said well
you know the Dark Dimension is a
dimension where they have physical
matter but they're nowhere near on the
same level as us in terms of their
capability so it's like sending Dormammu
and Umar to a primitive universe they
basically don't exist there but they
won't really be able to do anything the
opposite actually happens because of the
fact that you know Dormammu and Umar
crave physical matter or crave dark
matter once they end up in this universe
they realize that is nothing like the
fal teen universe the Valentin universe
is virtually energy there's really
nothing in terms of physical matter but
when they arrive in this universe it's
almost all physical matter because it's
so primitive and so the idea here is
that they can basically take things over
the problem is if they were to go
through and try to fight off against
these various wizards almost immediately
these wizards would probably be able to
take them out it would be a long and
arduous battle but they would probably
be able to take them out and so the best
way for Dormammu and
to take over the doctor the Dark
Dimension was by way of subterfuge and
so what they did is they monitored and
they watched King Olaf for time and came
to the realization that King Ola craved
conflict he craved the ways of old and
so they went to him and they said hey
look we are beings of magical energy we
can show you how to expand your universe
we can show you how to expand your
dimension to consume other dimensions
now of course again Roy Thomas doesn't
mean physically consuming them he means
much like the Roman Empire where they
just annexed other territories and
that's what it would be it would be you
know kind of creating these doorways
creating these dimensions there I guess
these are you know getting rid of these
dimensional barriers that would allow
onar and his forces to go in conquer
that territory leave a garrison behind
and allow him to be in control of it and
that's exactly what happens while the
Wizards of onar while they initially
protest they say hey Dormammu and Umar
are not what they appear to be the
desire of all are to return to the ways
of old overtake TSA's whereas his common
sense and so in response he follows the
instructions of Dormammu and Umar and
begins cutting a swath through all these
different dimensions that exist out
there in the Marvel Universe of the
Marvel multiverse but the problem here
is eventually he comes upon the universe
of the mindless ones now in Marvel
Comics the mindless ones have a very
long history and in a lot of instances
the mindless ones have operated as
agents of Dormammu but the mindless ones
are basically beings that have you know
energy about them there they have
super-strength but they usually use
energy projections things like that but
they're quite literally mindless they
just exist to do what they're told
nothing more but because of the fact
that they live in a universe where
they've been virtually unchallenged
they've moved to the point where they
have no direction where they just go
through and just destroy things Roy
Thomas is basically telling us the
mindless ones are an example of the most
primitive form of you know multi-celled
life in the sense that they just do
things and they don't know why and so
because of the fact that the dimensional
barriers between the dark dimension and
the dimension of the mindless ones have
been eroded the mindless ones invade the
dark dimension and just start killing
everyone I mean they kill off so many
people millions in the Dark Dimension
end up dying and so it was more or less
Dormammu and umar engineering a war now
of course a lot of the Wizards of the of
omar were killed although some did did
survive the experience but in the
conflict owner himself
the problem was that on our son was not
old enough to become ruler and so
because of the fact that Dormammu and
Omar had basically silenced those
Wizards who were able to reveal the
truth of the situation banished them to
the furthest reaches of the Dark
Dimension and then stood and defeated
the mindless ones the citizens of the
Dark Dimension rallied to their cause
and said these two wizards or these two
thought Indians saved our lives
they kept our dimension together we are
going to worship them as king and queen
and that's what happened they basically
elevated Dormammu and Omar to the
position of rulers now in truth what Roy
Thomas is telling us here is that this
would have happened regardless Dormammu
and Umar would have made themselves
absolute rulers of the dark dimension
whether or not the citizens went along
with it but the fact that the denizens
of this of this dimension went along
with it meant that it just made the
transition easier and so because of this
they you know Dormammu officially cast
off his human form that would be
recognizable by the viola and his ilk
within the Dark Dimension and took on
his foul team form which is basically
just flames and so during it during this
time which we don't really get a whole
lot here in terms of what it was that he
was doing we know that Dormammu began to
form allies began to form pacts with
other people in dark dimensions for
example he form pacts with with Odin and
Asgard now we don't really see a whole
lot of conflict between the two of them
and one of the biggest questions is who
would win Dormammu versus you know
versus Odin uh honestly is a toss-up I
couldn't argue either way but behind the
scenes the son of onar was growing older
and as he was growing over he was
started to become disillusioned with
Dormammu and umar but he didn't really
have the opportunity or didn't have the
means to overtake their position but
umar more or less granted this
opportunity and provided of providing a
scenario whereby she had intercourse
with the son of OMA and in response she
ended up having a child the issue with
this was that as a foul teen she wanted
to see the fountain legacy continued but
because of the fact that she gave birth
to a human child this ultimately led her
to going insane and in response she rose
up tried to overthrow her brother losing
her mind a Dormammu banished her from
the dimension and then door model
himself began to look towards the idea
of engaging in conquer
across the entirety of the multiverse
and so this is Roy Thomas basically
telling us this is the motivation of
Dormammu this is why it is that every
time we've seen him in Marvel Comics
emerge and become a villain or I guess
fight against Doctor Strange his
motivation has always been to overtake
all things in existence because that's
just what he wants to do he just wants
to conquer all life in the Marvel
multiverse now in truth the original
opposition that he faced was the ancient
one you know was that was the ancient
one going against him and basically
creating mystical barriers that would
keep Dormammu from being able to get out
of his own dimension now the reason why
this matters is because within the realm
of the dark dimension dormammu's at his
most powerful he literally feeds off the
energy zuv the dark dimension that's why
he's so capable when he's there and is
also why he's such a formidable threat
the issue is that much like Mephisto
beings like that when he leaves his
dimension he becomes weaker because he
doesn't have those energies to keep him
charged and so the longer he stays out
the weaker he becomes the longer he
stays out and the more energy he uses
the faster he becomes weaker and so this
is why he doesn't usually invade the
earth 6-1-6 dimension for any real
measure of time but if he were to find a
way to eliminate those mystical barriers
if you were to find a way to enter the
earth-616 mobile universe while
maintaining the energies of the dark
dimension
then according to dr. strange himself no
one who would be able to stand against
will ami not a single being in existence
now we don't know if dr. strange means
like the Living Tribunal and the one
above all would be destroyed or if all
eternity would have to do is show up and
everything's fixed
you know Doctor Strange doesn't really
give us that indication but the fact
that this is classic Doctor Strange
saying it which is Doctor Strange what
he was at his most powerful indicates
that for us as the reader if Dormammu
were to again enter the Marvel Universe
at full power being fully charged by the
energies of the Dark Dimension he would
likely lay waste to all things that
exist in the Marvel Universe he would be
completely unchallenged but with that
being said that is the origin of
Dormammu that is the origin of how he
came to be so if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you guys drop a light if
you are new year to comics explained
then be sure to hit the subscribe button
enjoying the Rob core and leave a
comment down below because I'm kind of
curious we might we might explore this
for next week I mean I've already
the idea of doing like spawn versus
ghostrider but we might do this next
week if there's a character that you
guys would like to see Dormammu face off
against from a non Marvel publication so
anybody not from Marvel Comics ah then
post that down in the description so if
you want to see der mal go against like
someone from DC or someone from valiant
or someone from image or something like
that dark horse then leave a comment
below and let me know who it is
that you think that Dormammu should go
against well we're going to bring this
video to an end and I will catch you all
later peace